gee I was actually more inclined towards
chemistry
maybe mathematics than biology in fact
in high school I never studied biology
at all because I found it much too soft
as a science then it was a
characterization of taxonomy and species
and phyla stuff that I found totally
boring
but in college at MIT when I was a
freshman I was planning to major in
possibly chemistry but I learned that
there was this new thing called
molecular biology that was just emerging
and there was it was very exciting so I
decided to try it out and I ended up
majoring in biology while taking a lot
of chemistry courses and I think it was
probably a very good decision because I
think the life sciences really have
blossomed tremendously in the past 10 20
30 years and this is really the golden
age now for biology
that came a little bit later so I had
been on the faculty at MIT for about six
seven years I had tenure and it gave me
an opportunity to think about doing
something a little bit risky sort of
high-risk high-reward and I spent
several years thinking what are some
problems out there in biology now that
would fit into that category and I
thought about a lot of things including
learning and memory and I thought aging
was was interesting because obviously
it's extremely important and it wasn't
being studied systematically it was
being studied from the point of view of
comparing old and young and mainly in
the medical community but in terms of
the aging process itself and moreover
what might control the aging process
there wasn't very much known there's a
little bit known but not much so it
looked like a perfect opportunity but
one that had considerable risk what made
me decide to actually get into it is it
turned out so my lab was at that point
studying the organism yeast and I was a
yeast biologist and we had studied
various aspects of cell and molecular
biology in yeast and that's really what
gained me tenure at MIT and it turned
out that yeast cells get old they age so
this was a for me a perfect entry point
to the problem we could begin by
studying how yeast cells get old and
that's what we did
we started bashing away at this problem
in yeast with the idea that we could
find genes single genes that could
confer extra longevity to yeast cells
that are dividing so when yeast cells
divide this is baker's yeast that I'm
talking about the kind of yeast you
would use to make bread or wine or
spirits and it turns out they're a very
very good system to study in the
laboratory to look at cell biology now
when these cells divide what you get
interestingly of course you get two
cells from one cell but they're
different one is called the mother cell
and it's big and the other is called the
daughter cell and it's small and it
turns out the daughter cell is all newly
synthesized all the material and the
daughter is new but the mother cell
retains the old stuff so that mother
cell will then give another daughter and
another daughter in every generation it
will be getting older and it does that
about 20 times and then it hits the wall
and senescence okay so that so it really
there really was aging albeit in a very
baroque system so we thought we would be
able to make some headway potentially in
identifying at least what controls this
process in this exotic system and that's
that's really what intrigued me I had at
that point no plan to study aging more
generally than yeast that came as we got
deeper and deeper into the problem